how Chrissy Teigen 'he's been hiding
that baby bump plus we're ringing in the
holidays with Sesame Street and my
one-on-one with the legendary Erykah
Badu hello everybody
let me tell you right now I am so ready
for the holiday weekend look I even got
a fresh cut for the occasion but but but
I still wanted to be here to give you
guys the latest and some exciting
entertainment news first of all my
favorites John Legend and Chrissy Teigen
announced yesterday they are expecting a
second child that's right another legend
is coming and they spilled the big
secret with the help of 19 month old
Luna baby
Chrissy captioned that video quote it's
John's the couple has been very open
about their struggles with fertility in
the past and et has learned it's a boy
which is what Chrissy told et would be
when they undergo IVF again now this
snap of Christie appearing to be months
along really tripped me out because
she's definitely been out in about the
last few weeks being photographed so how
does she hide her growing bump the
secrets in her fashion of course opting
for loose-fitting dresses and patterns
to disguise the growing belly at recent
events oh and you can't be an expertly
placed handbag you know I'm saying
alright either way that baby is gonna be
so well fed and I can only imagine what
Chrissy's table at Thanksgiving looks
like and now speaking of turkey day I
know all of you out there will be waking
up tomorrow watching the Thanksgiving
Day Parade
and this should come as no surprise that
my new pals over at Sesame Street will
be making appearance there again but
what are their big plants after the
parade well I found out what are you
guys's plans for Thanksgiving
well we like to spend a lot of time
together really that's what we do right
all of the our friends on Sesame Street
we we bring things together that we have
in our families we have some different
cultures that bring different kinds of
things in we all share them it's a lot
of fun a lot of fun and I'm sure a lot
of food right
yeah what do you guys most thankful for
this year his friends yeah Cookie
Monster told me he's also thankful for
cookies
that's right naturally by Cookie Monster
Big Bird and Elmo aren't the only stars
who will be at the parade et's very own
Kevin Frazier and Kelty night will be
hosting the big event for CBS so be sure
to tune in Thanksgiving morning
all right if you're looking for some
amazing live music this weekend then
look no further than the 2017 a Soul
Train Awards which airs Sunday on be et
they are hosted by Erykah Badu for the
third year in a row and I just sat down
with the music icon and we reflected on
twenty years of one of her biggest
anthems to date well it's between
anniversary of your live album the album
that spawned Tyrone one of the most
classic breakup songs I mean you posted
that that song it was almost a mistake
right kind of came together it just came
together on stage actually you know the
tradition of hip hop we just freestyle
on stage a lot and that song was
actually freestyle we used to play
around on the roads and rehearsal with
Norman keys on roads and he played
around the background singers and I
would play around with the melody called
them because it was a real soulful kind
of kind of thing and I got on stage one
night and gave keys the cue to play that
and the background singers with just a
look or not they understood that this is
what we're gonna do are you sure you
want to do this and I'm okay him I just
started and it just turned him to call
taro obviously I was on the radio the
next day it was on the radio the next
day in its live version and the only
time I had ever heard that happened was
from Betty right what she did tonight is
the night a long time ago what that mean
to you I mean two decades later that
riff that song has really followed you
around has been such a signature of your
music you know was it meaning was Amenia
now just feel you know
like it's an ex-boyfriend and just won't
stop following right it's in as a
blessing at the same time because it's
an anthem you know erica is everything
and she told me that there will not be a
follow-up to Ty Rome there's only one
Tyrone but ask for new music Erica says
she's just waiting for inspiration to
hit all right now speaking of soulful
music before we head out for the rest of
the week check out miss and Jennifer
Hudson just belting this gospel tune for
pentatonix Christmas special et's Kevin
Frazier got a special invite behind the
scenes
[Music]
I actually got a call I guess from a
pending Sonny's representative seeing
with Jennifer Hudson like to come and
saying how great thou art with the pen
in Tunney's and how great that art is a
very special song to me because my
grandmother used to lead it as a church
solo in church and then Christmas just
happens to be my favorite holiday and
then I love the pin and tonics so this
is perfect it's so perfect
[Music]
[Applause]
I mean come on take me to church J HUD
you guys can catch the full performance
on a very pentatonix Christmas Monday
night on NBC and like that we are
already talking about the holidays y'all
well listen I will miss you because we
will be back on Monday which is so far
away but we'll have a fresh video for
you then until then go enjoy your turkey
the fixings and your family and I just
want to say I am so thankful for you
also enjoy your holiday and I'll see you
on Monday